good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Tuesday if you
are in New York it is a beautiful smart
and stunning day here hey Claude hi Dern
hey Jax I'm doing good I had no idea it
was a nice day out because I don't open
my shades and I live in a bunker so good
to know good to know by the way someone
commented this and I think it's very
true that how you durn is the new good
morning Millennials
never it's the quarantine version of
good morning Millennials cuz you know
what it's not really morning and it's
not really good but how you durn know
but because it's also I haven't been
able to say it so it's like itching me
you know it's like wow that was mad
pitchy you are rusty Oh Susan you're
rusty please I don't know if it's just
like the Zoom audio maybe for the
podcasters it's premium but like my ears
are bleeding just don't ever call me
rest against us no but like that was
born in Millennials
good morning Millennials honestly it is
a great morning I want to start the
morning off with a high because last
night the most special thing of all time
happened to us for us by us with us from
the toasters a group of toasters got
together there was one poster in
particular shadow to Nancy who reached
out to as many toasters as Facebook and
Instagram would allow her and asked them
to send videos to compile for us a video
of what the toast means to them and you
know what their favorite parts are and
just like how it's helped them get
through their day or through a tough
time
I guess because she sense that you know
we weren't on our birthday today yeah I
didn't even realize how much I needed
that video it was the nicest sweetest
thing the video is 40 minutes it was so
special I was laughing I was crying
there were so many there was a few like
familiar faces from Camco stand from the
shows that I know but there were so many
new faces and it just made me realize
like the toast we're not just talking to
each other and ourselves when we sit
here and do this show
every day and like it means something to
so many people and they just like it
made me want to put earrings on which
you can't even see now I realize because
of my airport but I put on a little
Chanel earring for you guys and a plea
knee a sweater because like you guys
deserve it and I feel like we just got
so off track ya know it's like it's
difficult especially in quarantine not
to feel like there are five people
listening and I know we have analytics
may know that there's like so many
people listening but I don't know I've
just felt like so isolated in quarantine
to the point where like I feel like we
get up every day and like no one's
listening to this show and it's like
we're being so funny and nobody cares um
but that's not the case and I realized
that from the video and it's just like
reinvigorated my spirit like I have a
whole new spirit for life and I just
felt like what we do has purpose and
like when days are just not easy to get
out of bed and like be cheerful
especially in quarantine like knowing
that there's people who rely on this
show like for literally anything even if
it's just to get away from their kids
for an hour like that's important and
that adds value and like I am NOT gonna
stop doing it even though people want me
to I will not talk you can't get rid of
me yet yeah no we can't stop we won't
stop it was just exactly what we needed
what we didn't even know that we needed
like I had just like mentally I was on
the verge I was just like giving up like
phoning it in I was just done with all
of this but look at me today I'm a new
woman and that's thanks to the toasters
it was just it was really one of the
nicest things like anyone's ever done
for us um and we love you and we're so
thankful and thank you and you know what
it made me just like hearing what people
love about the community is so much
about the Facebook groups and it just
like made me sad that our group is like
not in session and obviously like it
really like I just want to tell you
reactivate the group last night just
like hearing what everyone said because
I know that those subgroups are like so
much a part of people's lives and it's
all funneled from the main group yeah so
it's definitely on my list of things to
have a meeting with you about I just
think there needs to be some major
changes and and a major purge yeah well
that was the first thing since all of
this has happened that was in the plus
column for the main group and I feel
like we're just evaluating seeing how
things go what people even want
we could even run a poll like do people
even miss the main group like I know the
subgroups are where it's at but it was
the first thing that got me thinking
like it's been a week now maybe the main
group I mean we know it wasn't all bad
but maybe the positivity is is shining
through again yeah and I think like some
of the plans I put together a PowerPoint
I'll send to you some of the plans I
have for how the main group moves
forward I think implementing these types
of ideas will in the end result in a
more positive community which is what it
used to be yes in addition to continuing
to take out the trash
Oh always I mean I'm taking out the
trash every day of my life that's just
all there is to do in quarantine we
acquire so much trash here in the
apartment but it is so important it's so
important to take out the trash during
client eeem you just can't live amongst
trash and it piles up like I don't know
if you're talking about real trash but
I'm talking about half day because
literally just between how much we're
eating and how much I'm just like living
in this house the trash I think it's the
truck check three times a day no it's
it's so important I would like a few
mini trash cans they all build up to one
trashcan it's there's a lot of trash
going on here and I actually do mean
legitimate garbage it's also is a
metaphor of course anyway so that's why
we have a little bit of pep in our step
the video was posted in the toast after
dark Facebook group I know a lot of
people had wanted to see it but it's up
to the toasters who participated if they
want to share it or not yeah it was just
a truly beautiful tribute like I was
walking around my house with a smile on
my face like trying to talk to bed I'm
like and then this one girl said and he
was like cool I'm like you don't even
appreciate your bite no I was laughing
so hard when the girl but had her
everyone was like toasting to the wild
ones and she was like in a toast to
women in country I was on the floor
I completely forgot about all of that
and then they throw back to the CMA fest
I was just dying yes that's so true
everyone was like me like it's just so
funny what sticks with people like what
stays in their group of friends and
things that I don't even remember saying
or they remember hearing from you have
like stuck with people and that's just
so funny I chose to women in country I
don't even remember saying that no when
we were on the CMA go to car band where
you're asking everyone what are they
toasting to tonight like literally 70%
of people said I'm toasting to women in
country and it was like it wasn't
planned
his plan also um the video just got me
like wanting to put my best foot forward
and I decided to take out one of my
fancy glasses today and because it's
like I have all these nice glasses
I used this like random coca-cola glass
from when Zach was a bachelor or
yesterday you just this little mason jar
and it wasn't enough coffee and I was
just like I can bring some style to the
show with what glass I use I just want
to say that these are plant based straws
I think everyone would be really proud
of me I switch over to plant they show
us a while ago um straws and oh and I'll
give you something they're so good
they're so good no okay in my defense
mine are not plant based they are
plastic but it's a bag I bought from
Amazon maybe two years ago like there
were so many straws in the bag
I won't be buying another bag but while
I have them and then I cut them up
before I throw them in the trash I feel
like that helps no that that helps and
it's better than to just throw them all
away like hole right now right and then
I'll send I took a picture of the label
of these plant base drawers because
they're so fabulous and I'm just really
living a plant-based life in the queue
yeah you know I love a PBS a plant-based
raw I mean I love it's actually a really
nice job I think you like it anyway so I
have my iridescent fancy glass I'm very
busy
I'm hitting you with those cleaning bags
and I didn't even realize like it's an
ode to the pastel pack that dropped
yesterday and people are saying the the
reviews are in there saying it's my best
work yet which is really layers which
really is flattering because like they
said that about like the last pack and
the one before that but this is really
like a whole new vibe if you're looking
to like amp up your content or in
quarantine even just edit pictures for
fun you can go down a rabbit hole just
adding presets to old photos head
jackieo flow calm get the new pastel
pack it is everything I'm sort honestly
I think I might like do a little photo
shoot today um in the home like just so
that I can use them and post something
we are just on different planets today
like I wanted to show my appreciation
for the toast like I did not put on any
makeup or anything different I think I
actually wear the sweater the day before
yesterday it's for my tour and I'm
definitely not gonna do a photo shoot
I'll probably just lay in bed and watch
shows all day but I so appreciate that
effort you're putting forward it's
inspiring things it just makes me I
like that's what I bring a lot of to the
Regular Show and also someone posted I
forgot which group it was in because
when I was posting my presets with my
old photos they were like this is making
me miss when like Jackie used to get
dressed up for the show and I'm like
honestly same so I thought I'd do like a
mix you know but I put on almost full
glam today I honestly don't really know
what steps I schedule there than eye
shadow and you can't even tell on Zoom
like it's not glam friendly no I'm
nervous that when all of this is over
I'm genuinely and going to forget like
the steps and the procedures that are
part of my everyday makeup routine like
I don't even know what the first step is
and I literally have been doing makeup
everyday for my whole life for like the
last at least eight years and I think
that when the day comes that I have to
put on makeup again like I'm gonna have
to watch a tutorial I'll watch my own
tutorial how about that oh that's really
smart I want to spend this time like
learning new tips and trades and
something that I'd really wanted to
learn how to do is like bomb eyeshadow
comes cut crease you know like the whole
nine yards so I think that might be like
an activity I do this week where I just
like sit down with all of my palettes
put on a few tutorials and learn how to
do my eyeshadow because I think that
would take my main look from zero to six
top look what I got well you know lunch
drag race but Kim Chi who is my favorite
you would have loved her Jackie she
spoiler alert didn't win but that's
because she was really just like a
makeup glam Queen and in order to be a
winner you have to be like a comedy
queen a look mean like you have to have
all and she really was just like stellar
in the looks department and I'm like
couldn't like be funny and couldn't act
but she started a makeup brand when she
was right after drag race and I think
it's like really very popular kisses mmm
that's nice oh I like I like the mixture
of neutrals and fun colors oh my god
wait there's a color called toast which
one oh that's a nice color that's like
what I put on my lower line I just um I
don't like know how to do eyeshadow but
I really appreciate like the pigments
and the packaging and I'm probably just
never gonna use it but let it look at it
all the time yeah that's that's where
I'm at with a lot of my palettes but I
think I'm gonna
I'm gonna like get an education in glam
like before the queue is up you know
there's still enough behind a good
tutorial there's still a lot of time
left you pick up new hobbies and like
new skills and so I'm gonna try and make
the most of it because the posters put
that pep in my step
totally I'm getting back into knitting I
just got my needles from Amazon I
started knitting I know I told her we
got everyone the spring break where
Marco started for the first time I told
the story last week if you want to go
into it
that's when I learned how to knit and
it's just a funny how certain things you
never forget like I was at my friend
Nicky's apartment like a few months ago
and she had like knitting needles and
she was like starting out and I'm like I
try and I just I just remembered like
it's crazy others like memory yeah
exactly thank you I couldn't think of
the phrase obviously because I'm done
I'm that muscle memory like really stays
with you and I literally was just like
knitting while I was sitting at her
apartment so I am going to get back into
it I can only make anything other than
like something linear so like a scarf or
like a blanket technically but that's
really big I think I can make do like a
mini scarf and that's what I'm gonna do
oh my god Claudia that's beautiful kids
tents it's the truth okay well I think
it's time to get into stuff you know
we'll go in and as we always do
I started the show never have I ever
which I want to talk about I saw that
you did that and I think that's all I
watched I would say actually good I'm
curious to get your thoughts cuz that's
something that I want to watch but I
need you to tell me if I'm too old for
it oh no I wasn't gonna say you're too
old for it I just don't know if you
would like it because I am NOT like
dying for it and there's a reason I'm
also only five episodes in but I feel
like that's a lot that is a lot I also
weirdly have like a lot coming up on my
slate cuz I've been like saving all this
stuff so like I'm still I'm just about
to start season two about me Betty I
still have Hollywood dead to me and
money high season four so I'm just like
and then soon the politician is gonna
come out then plot specials gonna come
out like it's gonna be crazy I'm so
jealous of anyone who hasn't watched
dead to me season two I was talking to
Olivia last night and she was like no me
and Zach I'm started like we're going on
they were just watching something else
and I was like Olivia don't take this
moment for granted like I'm so it was so
good or if anyone who's ever even
watched the show if you have now have
two seasons on Netflix of premium
[ __ ] content living in Laguna be
I just like wanted to be in that house
like it is so good and I'm just jealous
of people who are gonna have that
experience oh definitely well I guess
I'm one of those people and I very much
look forward to this oh can I tell you
you know I like I'm one coffee drinker
now oh so we never got to check in on
what happened that first day that you
drink coffee um I didn't really feel
anything
and yesterday I drink coffee - yesterday
I was so peppy on the show and I
definitely crash but I always scratch
the coffee then today I'm like starting
to get into a routine so go to the
kitchen and we're out of coffee like the
coffee that I've been using Ben and his
dad are obsessive lock column and they
get these cans right so that's what I
was using I was putting it over ice with
a little cream or hazelnut none none
sugar-free whatever it's called coffee
me my going and we're out of cans
[ __ ] kidding me I'm a jonesing now you
know I'm like an addict and Ben was like
alright this is what we do when we run
out of instant coffee I've let me run
out of the can they then had literally
the most disgusting kosher for Passover
kosher brand instant coffee I don't know
where the [ __ ] he got it so we put a
pitcher of hot water mixed it in left it
in the fridge and then we poured it over
ice and added my creamer and like a
little extra creamer like a million
sugars and it just tastes like a
milkshake now because there's like one
drop of coffee in it so I'm not that mad
um I just I'm like this is what never
what I wanted for my life to be like a
coffee person there's just like so much
time energy money that goes into like
finding the purple formula and I was
always above it you know but now I'm not
yeah I'm so below it like I'm so in the
coffee culture even though like my
coffee rhythm has just been out of step
recently um but something also very
exciting today it's just an exciting day
with a lot of pet because for the first
time since the first week of quarantine
I've been able to get an at-home grocery
delivery and it's coming today
when did you place the order I placed it
like two days ago there are time slots
it was it was like a seven-hour time sod
it's obviously not the most desirable
but like I'm home well hey what do I
care
oh my god that's crazy so I'm using it
to like buy all the beverages that
are too heavy for me to carry from the
store um and so they also have the cold
brew concentrate that I love that I
haven't had for months so hopefully
starting tomorrow I'll be back in my
coffee rhythm but I also think it's time
for me to get a new coffee machine and
I'm thinking about getting an espresso
I'm curious I'm curing coffee every
single day it's like such a big part of
my life like I you get what you pay for
it like I'm willing to invest in my
future mmm of coffee drinking so I'm
just curious what people think about an
espresso maybe I should try one
once at before I go and buy the whole
machine um I just like want to get my
coffee game more on planks I think it
would just make me more excited to wake
up in the morning if I hadn't knew I was
having like a great cup of coffee
um I feel that can I give a quick update
from yesterday we challenged our
audience yesterday on the show to either
watch heavy weights or tell us if they
watched heavy weights as an adult and
you have no connection to fat camp like
what you thought of the movie does the
movies still stand and I got an
overwhelming amount of messages being
like I actually recently just watch this
movie with husband and everyone's back
half and it's so funny like I think the
movie 100% exists outside of like our
childhood wait okay but this girl
commented on my photo saying toaster age
30 watching heavyweights for the first
time tonight will report back and I
hadn't heard back from her so I'm just
gonna go off of what she says because
like she is the exact subject like
someone who had never seen it age 30
so we'll see no I literally got messages
from people who are in their late 20s
early 30s who watched it in recent
memory and they said it was fabulous and
they're like I loved it
well Paige I'm waiting to hear back from
you my whole taste-wise paid better than
mine I just decided I just I just had it
at mindset it okay well like you have
your witnesses and I'll have mine and
then we'll take it to court and justice
will be served for once and for all no
justice has been served I have the proof
and it's just you know what if the glove
does not fit you must acquit if you must
that is true it's so tough
okay okay wait do we have that Allyson
Roman my part two story today we don't
cuz I personally was over it but I would
be happy to slot it in because the
stories are like week slot it in and not
because I find it interesting but
Chrissy Teigen wrote some very eloquent
and poignant tweets last night um just
about what it's like to be like the type
of person who's like unfiltered and
flippant and then like we get to travel
for and I actually related to it so much
it was just she was like putting into
words like things that I felt and the
story is that Alison apologized which
I'm gonna care about it was like
literally the best written apology ever
and we'll talk about it so is creating
apology yeah I thought it was like oh
yeah oh yeah yeah no it was nice I just
I couldn't believe that after like I
thought we were on the like the tail end
of reporting on this story and then
there was like more apologies to come
and I thought she really apologized and
obviously like she feels terrible and
just I can't stop saying sorry and I
hope that she feels a little better now
and I just pulled it up so I will slot
it in I guess Hannah Brown is gonna have
to take the backseat
um you can listen to the snatchler for
her statement on reflecting on her
journey from her and one year after
Colin Quinn said Oh glad that were me
too
me too okay without further ado et's
time for the past five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast today's
episode of the morning toast that would
be absolutely enormous absolutely
devastated I might even go as far as to
say that I would be heartbroken if I
didn't get the opportunity to tell
everyone that today's episode is brought
to you by care of harab launched in 2016
with a goal of honest guidance and
better ingredients personalized to
everyone's individual health needs in
2019 they launched protein and other
powders expanding their offerings to
help more people reach their health
goals now in 2020 they are extending
that same transparency and customization
with their skin and hair launched a line
of high quality supplements backed by
scientific research and made with
ingredients that are proven to support
beautiful healthy skin and hair care
helps you work on your beauty goals from
the from all angles with a combination
of targeted ingredients for hair skin
and nails
Karin listened when a lot of their
customers were looking for research
facts supplements for hair and skin that
actually works
you can use the Carib app to get
personalized milestones and rewards when
you remember to take your vitamins and
beauty supplements there are hundreds of
unity supplements on the market and even
if you find a brand that you trust it
can be hard to know what you actually
need or what we work for your specific
beauty goals the best part is that
there's no guesswork when it comes to
your carob beauty routine simply take
their online quiz and you'll instantly
receive your scientifically backed
recommendations based on your goals
lifestyle and diet they don't stop at
just hair skin and nails when it comes
to your beauty goals they dig deeper to
see if underlying causes such as
hormones sleep or digestion might be
affecting them in the first place carob
vitamins vitamin packs are compostable
so you can do right by yourself and the
environment and you can find information
how it can post the packs composed
campano sorry
I knew that Center on how you can find
information on how to compost the packs
on their website I feel like during
quarantine of course like what else are
you doing you should be taking care of
the inside and outside of your body and
hair skin and nails like we're all
getting a break we're not using heat
we're not wearing makeup we're not
wearing nail polish like we should be
nourishing the insides and that starts
as supplements and carob is taken care
of taking care of everything beauty
related and health related and
everyone's got it again on the carob
train and if it's not going to inquire
to you when is it gonna be um if you
want 50% off your first care of order go
to take care of comm that's ta ke CA re
o F calm and enter the code toast 54 50%
off your first order again if you want
to get 50% off your first order use the
code toast 50 toas t-50 a take care of
comm thank you and Kara for sponsoring
today's episode of the mornin most loved
it okay so I think for the first story
story let's start with the Christy
Teegan Towson room in drama because
we're on the tail of it and I have all
the tweets and I totally agree okay so
on Monday Alison Groban doubled down on
her previous apology to Tegan and
admitted her words came from her own
insecurities and white privilege quote
it was stupid careless and insensitive I
need to learn and respect the difference
between being unfiltered and honest
versus being uneducated and flippant so
um if you want to read her whole apology
which is Claudia said was very well
written head over to Allison Romans
Instagram page in response chrissy
teigen tweeted
um one second she said thank you for
this out syndrome and to be clear it
never once crossed my mind for you to
apologize for what you genuinely thought
the comments stung but they more so
stung because they came from you
it wasn't my usual news break of some
random person hating everything about me
I don't agree with the pile on people
waiting with bated breath for apologies
deciding if that apology is good the
people who say you were right and never
needed to in the first place there are
so many different types in this kind of
situation and tbh I just wanted to be
over I think we are alike in so many
ways I remember the exact time I
realized I wasn't allowed to say
whatever popped in my head that I
couldn't just say things in the way that
so many of my friends were saying before
I never really knew where I stood in the
industry in the world
eventually I realized that once the
relatable quote snarky girl who didn't
care became a pretty successful cookbook
author and had more power in the
industry I couldn't just say whatever
the [ __ ] I wanted the more we grow the
more we get those wake-up calls oh but
how I still think some of those things I
just don't only shun my peers on super
public platforms lol I often comment
about how I wish I could get away with
what I used to now but the truth is I
don't I learned a [ __ ] ton for my years
being watched and read and I can really
say it makes you a better person it
makes you think about the impact of what
you say
sascha who it might hurt I still think
you are incredibly talented and in an
industry that doesn't really lend itself
to supporting more than a handful of
people at a time I feel like we all all
we have are each other okay first of all
like cut that thread on my gravestone
like I couldn't stand by that statement
anymore like there are some times where
I wish I could just like say whatever
the [ __ ] I want and that's what I've
been branded as but it's like at the end
of the day she's right like being in the
public eye of course has its privileges
and disadvantages but like when you're
forced to like educate yourself and
eventually grow from saying to stupid
things like it really overall just
benefits you so I just thought that like
this was taken like from my subconscious
I thought it was brilliant but they're
two things going on here one that and
two I really feel like this apology was
like so it literally felt like uh the
New York Times wrote it like it was
perfect it just it it literally took all
angles of what people were mad at her
about she acknowledged that that she
didn't even realized the two women that
she spoke disparagingly about were both
Asian like what does that say about her
subconscious like I just
thought that it was so well done and
even though yesterday I thought this was
like major losery crime and it is like I
have absolutely no choice but to accept
the apology of someone who has obviously
made it clear that she like knows white
what she said was not good yeah I agree
and I feel like Chrissy Teigen is always
on the cutting edge of like canceled
culture even when like Vanessa Hudgens
said what she said Chrissy Teigen was
like let's not just pile on like people
are human like this is a real person and
so I feel like Chrissy Teigen has now
been on both ends of it like the
offensive and the efendi and her take on
it is just everything that we need right
now because like there are so many
people with so many different opinions
and like we don't all need to jump on
someone we also don't all need to be
like you don't need to apologize at all
like there is middle ground I actually
really hope that after this like the two
of them it seems like they would get
along and maybe we can move on from this
and they can be friends yeah there's
like a quote ingrained in my memory from
when Logan Paul got canceled for that
awful video that he made and Chrissy was
like not defending him and she was
speaking in general terms but she was
obviously talking about like the
cancellation that was happening at that
time which was Logan Paul and she was
basically like why can't you just like
stop supporting someone and not like
have to make a campaign or like a
hashtag about it like if somebody does
something to upset you of course as a
consumer you have every right to stop to
choose to stop supporting them but like
these these public like congregations
like with these movements of like trying
to ruin someone's life like that's look
why do we have to do that why can't you
just silently stop supporting someone
yeah I mean it's literally turned into a
party to end someone's career like how
shaken so is over party like wow I don't
get why that's a party for you like if
someone that you love is no longer the
person that you want to support like
that's that shouldn't be like a
celebration no it's sad yeah um anyways
I hope it's Chrissy Teigen also said
that she's taking a break from Twitter
um because obviously like it all starts
with people that support you and then it
turns into you know everyone else wasn't
opinion about you and she just um can't
write that was exactly another thing she
said that also was like literally in my
mind she was like you know
when you do something and like of course
all your supporters are there and
they're supporting you and then the next
day is when the trolls arrive like
they're little late to the party because
they don't follow you and they start
saying terrible things about you and
your family and your kids and that's
exactly how it happens and it's just she
really knows she has been there yeah so
I totally get that this has just been a
wild ride but I feel like it's cool over
yeah so that's ID on that and that's on
period okay
next worry a really crazy story that
Claudia sent me this morning that um I'm
really shook over the intercom rules
editor admits to a personal vendetta
against scheana Shay after a season
filled with humiliating montages on
Vanderpump rules
scheana Shay finally has an explanation
for what happened in the cutting room
Bree Dellinger an editor on the hip rabu
show appeared on episodes 1 & 8 of the
twisted plot podcast with Evelyn Marley
and revealed exactly why Shea's gotten
the seeming lion's share of
embarrassment in the show's final cuts
quote if scheana knows what's good for
her she'd befriend me because my
favorite game is finding all the
embarrassing things that Sheena does and
putting them all in she quipped on one
episode she later joked that if Shay was
to write a memoir the title should be
death by a million embarrassments and
while she didn't see it which cast
members she gives more favorable edits
to she admitted that she manipulated the
scene between scheana and stassi's
teenage brother Nikolai at the
engagement party quote it was so funny
we were watching the scene and we're
like okay this is over-the-top I realize
that but how can we resist yes I set it
to funny music and I added a funny sound
bite but she did that she continued
quote we asked her in the interview how
young would you go and we didn't tell
her it was for the Nikolaj scene of
course and inside a reveal to page six
on Monday after the episodes were
mysteriously removed from Apple podcast
that Shay has been upset by the way
season 8 has played out
Sheena's definitely frustrated with how
she's been portrayed the insider said
she's not the type to pop off when she
feels slighted by an unflattering at it
she signed on to be a part of the
reality show which requires her to share
her life's highs and lows she goes
wishes audiences got to see a more
balanced view of her life not just the
most Quinn cringe-worthy moments
she's been assured by the network in
production that she's part of the
charade she's going to be absolutely
crushed by hearing but she's actually
the butt of the joke
also what this article de dimension is
that later on in the podcast and this
editor like was praising Stassi
Annabelle about how they're the heroes
and of course like when you think of who
gets a favorable edit and who doesn't
like it's obviously Stassi like look
what look what she got from the show
it's like so many fans podcast listeners
books and obviously she's great but
being edited in a positive light these
last three seasons has definitely helped
catapult that yeah I mean any sort of
edit I'm sure a great editor can make
Sheena like the most likeable character
on the show and yes you could argue
Sheena has done those things but when
you choose to show someone's only
embarrassing moments and not the balance
of their human moments you it's it's
warped and like I think this is so
[ __ ] up and like the fact that she's
joking about it like this is someone's
life and you know what like Sheena has
been the most cringe tastic character
this season and every like once in a
once in a blue moon we get a glimpse of
like your human side when she started
crying about like freezing her eggs and
this wasn't where I wanted to be and it
kind of explains all the other childish
stuff that she does but if you're saying
there's more of those moments and you're
just not showing them to us coz you want
us to see her as this one-dimensional
embarrassing figure like this is not
nice ya know like there's definitely
okay this editor like really has a
vendetta against Sheena which there's
honestly no way you can deny especially
not only because she admitted it but
like Sheena's literally been absent from
the last few seasons and the parts that
we do see are so cringy and embarrassing
and it's like you think that's her 24/7
but there's obviously like a lot more
moments to her that are very earnest or
whatever like she's doing this through
this whole fertility treatment like joke
I think people would have wanted to see
that like other women going through the
same thing like to have left that out
such an important part of someone's life
like seems odd now it all makes sense
and to not only have a vendetta against
someone which everyone's entitled to but
like to take it out on life your job is
weird but then Talebi so publicly like
proud of it and go on a podcast and talk
about it where you obviously don't think
you're doing anything wrong like it
seems so [ __ ] up and like Sheena was
on one yesterday like she was literally
tweeting with Angie DME I have tea and
she obviously gave this story to page
six I saw it on like a couple of fan
accounts for like Andy Cohen fan
accounts and venom from pearls fan
accounts and honestly I'm glad that
people are
talking about it it's actually like
really [ __ ] up and if I think about
the way that I perceive scheana over the
last few seasons it's like cringy and
like we made fun of her and it's like
honestly she probably didn't deserve
that yeah it's just not the whole story
and that's not there because everyone
else has there even like Raquel and
James like everyone has their redeeming
moments and Sheena just never gets that
shown on the show um also Sheena had
tweeted a few weeks ago when the Nikolaj
thing aired that that was like taking so
out of context and of course you're like
well you did it but like when you're
manipulating the interviews versus
what's happening on the show and putting
music like it's it's not right and I
feel like for reality TV especially a
show like the inner pump roles where
there's so much there without you having
to like craft things like this um it's
just like it's 20/20 like this is
missing one this isn't season one of The
Bachelor like you know we're gonna get
these girls to say crazy stuff like let
the kids live and like just show us
their lives we were fans of them as they
are now like it doesn't require that
much manipulation yeah it must be
frustrating for Sheena to have to
explain herself after every episode and
when she did tweet that thing like this
conversation with Nikolai was nothing of
the sort
um saucy actually replied it was like I
was air was not weird like really um
like having her back which made me happy
because Stassi who's who is someone
who's gotten such a favorable at it not
the whole series but definitely in the
last few seasons
um it's clear that they like her and to
me like there was nothing shocking about
this page six article no but it's it's
it's shocking to just see it all written
like plain out you know something that
you were feeling but like I never gave a
second thought to it was just like wow
she knows really like worse than ever
yeah and it really just is so unethical
yeah cuz it's someone's life yeah and I
get that they signed up for this I get
it but they signed up to share their
lives and that's what they do but to
have it be so manipulated of course
there's things that get left on the
cutting room floor and of course they
play music sometimes but just to have
this person's entire storylines and last
I would say four seasons have everything
they do be so manipulated which I feel
like it's been now that I know this it
makes me feel bad for Tina yeah but I
feel like yes they signed up for it but
I I feel like they all signed up for
equal playing
amongst cast members like if you want to
embarrass every single cast member then
then that would be more fair than just
singling out one person while you raise
everyone else up yeah agreed that's my
thoughts on that
honestly justice for Sheena never
thought I'd say it but it's so true yeah
okay next story a little good news Tina
Fey tears up as a telethon raises 115
million dollars for New Yorkers affected
by covin at 19 Tina Fey was brought to
tears over the generosity of Americans
who reached out to help to help New
Yorkers affected by the corona virus
pandemic on Monday night the emmy winner
and SNL alum was hosting rise of new
york the robin hood relief benefit a
star-studded virtual telethon raising
money for the city's leading poverty
fighting organization when she got
emotional while reading the final tally
is this real she asked producer seeing
the number for the first time okay a
hundred and fifteen million we did this
you did this we are difference makers
115 million what a great day for New
York that special was fabulous like they
really had quality celebrity quality
talent quality performances Billy Joel
it was very very well done and I don't
say that about a lot of these like
homegrown specials no you do not wow
this is like so amazing Robin Hood is a
great organization and they're turning
their efforts towards helping New
Yorkers affected by koban 19 and this is
just such a beautiful story right and
like we've gone to Robin hood-like
fundraiser once it feels good to know
that 115 million dollars is going to
like a legit organization who's like I
in New York I have seen the fruits of
their labor like it's not some of these
um charities are just so ambiguous and
like you really never know what's being
done with the money but Robin Hood it's
like in the communities it's really
great so I hope that this helps a lot of
people yeah some of the a-listers who
participated Jennifer Lopez Robert
DeNiro Bette Midler Sarah Jessica Parker
Matthew Broderick Chris Rock Jake
Gyllenhaal Sutton Foster Rosie Perez
Jimmy Fallon salt-n-pepa's out five
Trevor Noah Danny Meyer David Chang
Beastie Boys I love that they got like
New York ghosts yeah me too it's great
it's great okay miss a story like
brought
a warmth like whatever the opposite of a
pit is like a glow in my stomach what is
the opposite of a pit like something I
just warmed the cockles of my heart like
it we need to come up with a word yeah
Kylie Jenner's daughter stormy chanting
patience in the candy challenge is the
cutest thing you'll see all week Oh near
Kylie Jenner posted a video of stormy I
guess there's a candy challenge going
around where you like tempt your child
with candy and see if they wait till you
come back you film them you see if they
wait till you come back to eat the candy
as you had said so Kylie share this
video of us where she left the phone
while she told stormy was going she was
going to the bathroom and we're just
watched or me sitting there like
willpower at its finest chanting
patience to herself as she waits for her
mom Kylie to get back so that she can
eat three pieces of candy it is the
cutest thing I've ever seen it's the
cutest thing I've ever seen and I feel
like it's a real window and like a
testament into what type of kids stormy
is and she looks like she's such a good
kid I'm like Kylie such a good mom not
that I ever thought otherwise but you
know celebrity kids can be monsters like
we know that like she just seemed like
such a lovely girl yeah like so
respecting rule-following
obviously very he full of willpower um I
don't know it's like an interesting
social experiment to conduct on your
children and I guess this is obviously
the best possible result it's just
interesting yeah oh my God my just rich
um it's a trend that's on tik-tok that
I've seen and it's it's like a famous
science experiment it's like the
marshmallow challenge I remember seeing
it like when I was in like science grade
class in the sixth grade
um and honestly as an adult I don't
think I could pass no and stormy pass
with flying colors flying she's so cute
yeah I wonder what like scientifically
this says about her obviously it's a
science experiment like but what are we
experiment like what are we proving
what's a hypothesis yeah I thought the
sisters that Kylie Jenner's a great mom
in her new house looks fabulous yeah I
think that's what we were what was
proven as well and Kim commented she was
like oh my god this is so crazy like
Chicago would never
would never she was like putting her own
kids on blast it was really funny really
funny speaking of own kids
if you're watching on YouTube the
Chairman has entered the chat the
Chairman has entered the chat he's
looking for a place to just get cozy
he's in the log Zak I feel like I'm
narrating National Geographic he's
looking around I wonder what he's
looking for he he can't get comfortable
I wonder why he's going round and around
looking for something perhaps buried
treasure who knows what is in there oh
did he just get a bath well he looks
like he's wet and trying to dry off up
he plopped he plopped down okay the
fisherman is in the sack that was so
beautiful
tried to like force him to become like
in love with the loves act like I am and
he wasn't really taking to it like he's
very set in his own ways and he's not
gonna change for any woman or man and
the fact that he just like jumped in
there when I've literally thrown him out
there 500 times since quarantine started
means that it's working yes he has been
sacrified okay it's earnest fifth and
final story Richard kind is the latest
art attached to the tiger King parody
musical and your public Jackie why do I
care who was Richard kind I'll tell you
is Richard kind from Seinfeld is he
Funkhouser Seinfeld from curb oh sorry
curb
I don't think she's like Funkhouser he's
from red oaks he's our dad yes yes I
thought he was Marty's cousin no that's
um Vince Vaughn but he please incur but
he plays like his like Larry's cousin or
something Oh exactly what is he's the
dad from red oaks and he was so sad in
that row so sad Richard Klein is the
latest star to join a cast of Tony
nominated composer Andrew LIPA's Tiger
King the musical apparentiy LIPA's Tiger
King inspired Tunes have recently been
recorded as outrageous home videos by
Kristin Chenoweth Frankie Grande and
RuPaul's Drag Race star Nina West now
people are legitimately calling and
saying I want to be involved he tells
page six
my friend Richard kind wants to be a
part of this year revealed that adding
kind will sing as Howard Carol Baskins
husband Chenoweth played Baskins
liberals working his way to his way up
to a show-stopping Joe exotic tune and
says what I really want is Jared Leto to
play sang tricks now imprisoned former
big cat owner Joe exotic Jared Leto
that's good Jared Leto sings I didn't
realize it was musical now is this the
same one as Nicolas Cage and Kate no no
this is like a parody that has been just
circling on the internet he said it's
unclear if the project began just for
fun if it might if it might one day come
to a real stage I feel like this is the
best way for a project to be born like
it starts as a joke people like it
galvanizes people and people are excited
and all of a sudden it's on Broadway and
it's winning Tony's like that is
exciting I never told you that I ended
up watching that Carol Baskin prank
video of that about those guys who
tricked her into going on Jimmy Jimmy
Fallon when it was really just their
YouTube channel and I had some strong
words about it when I walked when I just
heard about it because I thought it was
like kind of fucked-up and unethical but
when I watched it it was really well
done and they did a great job and I
loved the vlog showing the intricacies
of like what email accounts they made
like how they really got her on the show
and they got a statement from her
afterwards saying like she had a feeling
it was fake because all the questions
sounded pre-recorded but it was a funny
joke but she wasn't mad about it um and
it didn't give me as big of a pin as I
thought it was going to yeah I guess
it's nice that they didn't like use the
opportunity to you know embarrass her
make her uncomfortable but still the
premise it's just not something that
like I think we should be oh yes
yeah but it's like this thing that they
do on this channel it's like a popular
UK youtube trend I saw a lot of videos
about it this one obviously just got the
most press she had asked it they just
don't talk about the documentary at all
and they agreed so the questions were
like pretty harmless like how many cats
do you have
so it really it wasn't as bad as I
thought it was gonna be I have to say
okay
TV recap time yet see me recap time
brought to you by Beachbody on demand
it comes as no surprise that we're all
stuck in our homes for a while avoid the
complacency it's important now more than
ever to stay active and keep working out
work out and even take classes in the
comfort of your own home with Beachbody
on demand the easiest the easy-to-use
streaming service that gives you instant
access to over 1,300 super effective
workouts suited for anybody at any time
the secret to getting results is just
getting started this is a same company
that is behind p90x insanity and 21 day
fix and now you can check out some of
the beach body's newest programs like
morning meltdown 180 day obsession and
start every day strong they have some of
the best trainers and the best programs
that you can workout on your own
schedule they've worked out too short is
ten minutes to jump require extra
equipment you can access it anywhere at
any time so your computer web enabled TV
tablet smartphone Roku Apple TV
chromecast and more it's the best deal
in fitness because listeners and the
morning shows can try it absolutely free
um if you want to try this service you
can get a special free trial membership
when you text toast to 30 30 30 you'll
get full access to the entire platform
for free all the workouts the
nutritional information and support
totally free again just text toast to 30
30 30 Jackie and I have been loving a
lot of the programs especially the
morning meltdown because you know you do
the morning toast and then you get the
morning meltdown or you do morning melts
out and then wanting to house it's up to
you whatever your schedule for this
which body is just one of those things
that was like made for quarantine and
has really elevated my quarantine
situation just like switching it up
getting active and doing different
things I really I'm loving Beachbody
currently okay TV recap let me talk to
you about never have I ever I had gotten
so many recommendations from it for it
and I started to watch it and the first
thing I notice is that it is filmed on
Wisteria Lane I don't know if you saw my
Instagram I saw it's this like suburban
neighborhood they built a new house for
Debbie's family like the the main
character her family is not like a
recognizable home but I saw Susan's
house I saw Bob and Lee's house I saw
the Solis house it's just it's honestly
the best part of the show like truly a
trip down Wisteria Lane um now the show
the show is good it has a lot of
redeeming qualities um I do not like the
main character like her priorities are
so [ __ ] up
just like a teenager in like she's like
good friends and she has a good life and
her parents are like her mom is like so
lovely and she's just like all she cares
about is having sex like it's just it's
and I get like wanting it she just has
so many blessings in her life and she
doesn't thinks her life is terrible you
know and I just hate kids like that um
and she's like I just know what's gonna
happen she's like gonna you know try to
be too cool for her friends and then her
nerdy friends are gonna want her back
like I just she kind of bothers me um
and the show is narrated by John McEnroe
and there's a reason why and it's really
not that great of a reason like he was
like hi I'm John McNamara and I'm now
writing the show you'll find out why let
me find out why I'm like I still don't
understand why you're now writing the
show and they gave him like a um like a
script written by like a nine-year-old
trying to be a millennial you know he
says things like that's lit and it's
just the narrating and fathering me it's
like a trend in Netflix not like you
have a narrator like too hot to handle I
I don't like it like they try so hard to
be like funny and millennial and I
talked to teenagers and it's not it the
show is not bad on the episodes are nice
and short I just am not like loving it
and it got such um positive feedback but
I'm not getting that but it's not bad I
can't explain like I actually really
like how they dive like because it's a
Mindy Kaling production they talk so
much about Indian culture like the more
and learn more about other cultures and
I realize like we are all the same like
the way they were talking about like
classic like Indian mom stuff like it
could have been classic Jewish mom stuff
like it was really very similar um it's
good I actually like a lot of like the
cultural stuff like one of the cousins
it has to get arranged marriage but she
falls in love with this guy College I
like that but like the high school stuff
it's like not what it's like it's not
doing it for me and I live for high
school stuff you know yeah well maybe
like we're phased out of high school
stuff that's what I meant when I said
I'm too old like sometimes when I read
books or watch movies about like kids in
high school now I'm just like I'm sits
just not me
do you still enjoy like to all the boys
I've loved before I do because like it's
so well done it's impossible not to
enjoy it but recently I've just come to
the conclusion
like when it comes to high school he
things I'm just not in high school like
I'm far from it
wow that's actually crazy cuz it's still
my favorite genre of film like I've I've
just been big me about how so many of
those types of movies that we've been
watching like since they were too young
like we were seeing girls when we were
like eight like oh but like when I watch
movies from when we were in high school
and like the movies that we grew up with
about high schoolers those I loved
because like those are my people but now
being 15 years older than these people
um it just makes me feel old I guess I
didn't get that feeling I don't think
that's why I'm not loving it I think I
don't know what I'm not loving about it
but it's just people are saying it's
like the perfect show and it's just not
but it's good interesting well I'm glad
that there's content yeah and then I
also watched some more RuPaul drag race
I've kind of slowed down because I was
watching last season today and it was
just it gets very monotonous because
it's the same thing every time like
mini-challenge challenge runway
Chantelle you say like it's just it's
very monotonous um but I'm on season 10
now and I just want to make a prediction
on like episode 7 I think Eureka wins
and that's all I'll say can not stand
it's in such a mean they're all living
for age not like maybe one of the most
beautiful Queens um who's ever been on
the show like the makeup is just getting
so good like I need to have a drag queen
do my makeup like the way that they just
give themselves perfect faces and like
lift up everything everything of a sort
yeah Wow that's what we need to learn in
the queue I've just been watching Ugly
Betty I didn't start watching TV until
so late last night
um because I just found ways to busy
myself and then I watched the toaster
video which was 40 minutes so I probably
started watching TV at 9:30 I caught two
episodes of Ugly Betty and now when I
start watching tonight I'll be on season
2 which is exciting I love when like I
love a glow-up between like seasons on
shows and I I look forward to seeing the
differences between season 2 and season
one in Ugly Betty yeah like with the
show like that it's like the first
season you don't know if you're gonna
get a second one then the second one
comes to get more budget more wardrobe
and it just elevates it yeah so I'm
really excited for that but I'm still
loving it like it totally holds up I've
seen that other people have started
watching it um that might be hist and
they are thoroughly enjoying it as well
so I think this has been
decision for me and I'm just gonna keep
watching it until I can't no mo yeah
that time is gonna come like that always
just always yeah whether the show Peters
out or I Peter out or I run out of
episodes like there will come a time
when you know I think I have a good
solid week with it last okay that's not
gonna enjoy it yeah I'm gonna enjoy it
yeah um and then what's on your docket
I'm gonna watch
I'm gonna finish never have I ever and
then I want to watch the new Jerry
Seinfeld special I heard it was good um
on my docket is I think after this I
wonder what I'll watch first ed to me or
Hollywood
I think I'll watch Hollywood first then
dead to me season two and then uh money
heist I just I just feel like you're
never gonna watch money heist I know
because you just like get so sucked into
it I don't know but the more I keep
putting it off the better like I just
need to have things to look forward to
yeah totally that's the key to our team
cannot wait for my yarn to get here like
that's my big excitement of the week
even if I never watch money high season
for like I will always have it to look
forward to that's true we'll always have
money heist yeah that's a great name for
today's episode
um today's episode is the one with the
pep in our step um so I actually just
texted her and she said that she's done
writing if you are yeah she said that
her wrist hurts and she's [ __ ] done
so maybe she got a computer and she can
type instead so I guess that's all she
wrote she also wanted to let you know
that she was like getting a little
wishy-washy with the writing because
she's just been like editing her photos
like jhaquiel some presets and you
should get some to head over to Jackie O
blow comm to get your flow on and poppin
yeah she said those mean she was like
sending me selfies of herself like in a
cotton candy sky and it was Nate Lee
she's like really feeling herself thank
you guys so much for listening to the
morning show similarly I morning show
when we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so be
watching i7 youtube please subscribe and
give this video a thumbs up we are also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
we found so it's spotify itunes stitcher
public radio i already their press box
all the places wherever you listen to
podcasts - more interesting five star
view about it beautiful stunning and
smart we are we love you guys
much have a great time bye